[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight man the world is
changing fast we say that often because
it's true it's kaleidoscopic every
morning you wake up in a brand new
country
and it's hard to keep track of the
change because there are so few mile
markers
but here's one here's one measure of the
change it was less than a year ago that
millions of us gathered around our
electronic hearths in anticipation of
andrew cuomo receiving a coveted emmy
award you remember that night
even by the standards of fraudulent
hollywood ceremonies it was a very weird
moment
as a rule politicians do not accept emmy
awards that would require admitting that
they're actors but andrew cuomo
post-modern as he is had no problem with
that he's been playing a character from
the godfather for decades
so he took it
here are the highlight clips they played
as andrew cuomo received his statuette
flatten the curve flatten the curves
flatten the curve we talk about social
distancing slow the spread new york has
been getting the short end of the stick
from this federal government
from day one right across the board
let's stop
just for one moment
the partisanship
flatten the curve flatten the curve
flatten the curve
it's iconic
it's like go ahead and make my day or
may the force be with you we'll never
forget it it will live on forever in our
common culture
and so you can see why andrew cuomo won
best performance by a sitting governor
such passion such intensity
the delivery seemed almost lifelike in
its sincerity and force talk about
method acting
for a second you could almost imagine
andrew cuomo running a large american
state
sitting in his office in the capitol
building making complex policy decisions
about whatever they make complex policy
decisions about
barking urgent orders to aids like a
governor
it was a remarkable performance in fact
looking back that night at the emmys
last november was the apogee of andrew
cuomo's career
and he could have lived on it for years
dining out mining the memories of his
heyday playing progressively smaller
venues doing an annual fan show in san
diego
but he chose not to
andrew cuomo is wiser than that he's
bigger he remembers well what happened
to marlon brando when the godfather
series ended the long decline
so today andrew cuomo quit the business
he left at the top of his game here's
his announcement
wasting energy on distractions
is the last thing that state government
should be doing
and i cannot be the cause of that
new york tough
means new york loving
and i love new york
and i love you
and everything i have ever done
has been motivated by that love
and i would never want to be unhelpful
in any way
and i think that given the circumstances
the best way i can help now
is if i step aside and let government
get back to governing
he's so tough he's running away he's so
tough he's quitting
we've heard that claim a lot recently
and you know watching that tape it is
possible that we have sold andrew cuomo
short we told you his emmy in november
was the high point of his career but in
fact what you just saw may have been the
single greatest performance of his life
i'm resigning he said not because i
killed all those old people in nursing
homes no not because my closest advisor
went to federal prison for corruption
nothing to do with it not because i've
got a super creepy personal life and by
the way it's entirely possible i am a
made member of the mafia no not at all
i'm resigning from my job because i love
the state of new york and ladies and
gentlemen that's what love does
it resigns
pretty remarkable really could al pacino
have delivered those lines with a
straight face no not a chance
but instead of enjoying it the media
missed it naturally
they missed the art of it entirely they
bought the whole thing they took it
seriously they thought it was real today
they're telling you that andrew cuomo's
resignation is a watershed moment it's a
win for the metoo movement it's a somber
reminder the systemic misogyny that
surrounds us
on cnn they got completely carried away
as they often do one particularly
self-hating male anchor is there any
other kind over there was so awestruck
by andrew cuomo's speech that he
immediately yielded the floor to the
ladies to his female colleagues
it would be wrong he said for a man to
weigh in on news this grave that's how
toxic andrew cuomo is intercom is a
living embarrassment to men everywhere
even the news readers who periodically
identify as men on cnn
that's what they're telling you
now far be it for us on this show to
defend andrew cuomo he is awful we've
said that for years and we haven't
changed our view
but still since this is playing out in
public it might be worth asking a couple
of obvious questions before we move on
to the next victim
for example if andrew cuomo was
harassing so many women and doing it at
the state capitol in new york how come
we just learned he was doing it andrew
cuomo has been in office for almost 11
years
lots of people say now that they knew he
was a creep
so why didn't they tell us before they
certainly didn't instead they told us
andrew cuomo was godlike do you remember
that in case you don't remember it we
have the tape
governor cuomo
out there day after day after day
everything trump isn't honest direct
brave even lifelong republicans tell me
they look at cuomo and they're like god
there's a leader for those of you who've
been wondering why
new york governor andrew cuomo has been
garnering the nickname america's
governor i think you saw it right there
he is conveying incredible strength in
the face of this pandemic maybe trump is
just a little bit mad that governor
cuomo has been kind of become a kind of
acting president i hope you are able to
appreciate what you did in your state
and what it means for the rest of the
country now and what it will always mean
to those who love and care about you the
most
turns out noted feminist icon joe
scarborough liked the cut of andrew
cuomo's jib
and honestly that should have been a tip
right there the race lady was a fan too
in retrospect those were pretty clear
signs we should have picked him up but
here's the most obvious sign america's
most prolific hair sniffer was a massive
fan of andrew cuomo's i mean of course
he was these guys all know each other
your governor new york's done one hell
of a job he i think he's he's sort of
the gold standard i mean
look at the way you have governors like
cuomo who are out there doing just
keeping everybody informed all day i
think he's doing an incredible job i
think he has been the lead horse here
i've talked to him frequently he's a
friend
uh i think he's doing a great job i
really mean it
he's the gold standard he's doing a
great job he's a friend i really mean it
and you know they all meant it until
just about in fact precisely december of
2020.
that's when a candidate for manhattan
bureau president a woman called lindsey
boylan wrote a twitter thread that
accused andrew cuomo of quote harassing
her sex harassment the crime according
to boylan occurred more than two years
earlier in 2018 but we hadn't heard
about it
so here's the first question why did
lindsay boylan wait two years to tell us
what had happened
this guy is the governor of one of the
most important states in the country
so why didn't she pipe up before say
before the emmy awards
now we can't know the answer to that but
it's clear that she picked a politically
significant moment to share her
allegations on twitter lindsey boyle
went public almost immediately after the
news media called the presidential race
for joe biden
oh
could it be that the second that call
was made andrew cuomo had outlived his
usefulness and it might be time to crush
him and move on to someone who's easier
to control
now if you think that's a conspiracy
theory you don't live in new york where
that kind of thinking is common the
state of new york has a long history of
palace coups and many of them a
disturbingly large number originated in
the attorney general's office in fact
andrew cuomo once did it he was the
attorney general of new york remember
that
he used his office to investigate his
boss at the time elliot spitzer the guy
who wore black socks all coming back to
you and then he became governor
oh so this is the kind of thing that
happens in new york that's not exactly
democracy it's like late ottoman but
it's very common there could it be
that's what's happening now
well let's see the current attorney
general of new york is a woman called
letitia james now james does not hide
her own political ambitions because you
no longer have to nobody cares earlier
this year she said that a.g you thought
it meant attorney general no actually
she said it stands for aspiring governor
which she is
even before she was elected to her
current office which she is misused from
day one james vowed to start a political
investigation into donald trump's
businesses in new york not because she
had specific evidence they had broken
the law she didn't she didn't even claim
she did but because she didn't like him
and she since followed through on that
promise is that the kind of justice you
want
so there are reasons to question latisha
james's motives to put it mildly
and those doubts become far more
pronounced if you become one of the
three living americans who's actually
read the 165-page report that she just
produced on andrew cuomo the report that
led to his resignation today
now the closer you read that report the
more you are likely to notice that large
portions of it are absurd
they don't make sense on page 148 for
example latisha james accuses andrew
cuomo of quote allowing senior staff
members to sit on his lap at official
functions now that sounds kind of creepy
as hell actually and latisha james
clearly thought it was she goes on to
characterize lap sitting as evidence of
quote a hostile work environment
all right
but if you go back to page 122 of the
same report you will notice this line
quote
none of these senior staff reported
feeling uncomfortable with this behavior
oh so they liked sitting in andrew
cuomo's lap weird but who are we to
judge weirder things are happening right
now
so how is this harassment how is it a
violation of the law she's the attorney
general her job is not to pass moral
judgment on the occupants of high office
in new york but to enforce the laws
passed by the legislature that's why she
has the awesome power to do that which
she must not un under any circumstances
misuse or else it's a threat to all of
us even those of us who loathe andrew
cuomo
but the report and you should read it
maybe it's irrelevant now is full of
lines like that the kind of
inconsistencies you would expect if
you're pleading reading say a political
tract not a legal document
but again it doesn't matter now because
the report did its job
now the race for a new governor of new
york is underway boy that didn't take
long candidates are lining up to unseat
the lieutenant governor kathleen hoechel
she set set to take over when cuomo was
gone
now leticia james is the first in line
but she's not the only one in line al
sharpton is in line so is new york mayor
bill de blasio they're both planning to
run for governor we read
so do you see how this works
andrew cuomo was an awful governor
it pains us to raise any voice in his
defense he was a vicious partisan he was
a thug
but if we're being honest he was not
completely insane he wasn't totally
untethered from reality he acknowledged
some limits to constitutional government
he wasn't saying leticia james he wasn't
al sharpton he wasn't even we're pausing
to catch her breath here because it's so
horrifying he wasn't even bill de blasio
the most reckless and incompetent human
being ever to hold elected office a man
who single-handedly discredits the idea
of self-government
these people just being honest are worse
than andrew cuomo
but because someone sat in andrew
cuomo's lap they may soon run the state
of new york just so you know what's
actually going on here hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else